Citizens of Botica, it is my great
pleasure to welcome you on this...
...the New Deal and the liberation of
the five kingdoms' 50th anniversary!
Hail King Bulgher!
And it is my greater pleasure...
...to celebrate the birthday of my
beloved son and heir, Prince Kelby!
Highness, the prince cannot
be found. Begging your pardon.
This is troublesome. Find the prince!
As you wish.
A slight miscommunication.
Please, go on with your reveling!
Come on, Sam.
The fireworks are starting!
Right!
Now this is more like it.
I've many fun
memories atop this old tree.
It’s a precious friend,
right next to you.
That’s sweet of you to say.
But it's your birthday.
Shouldn't we return to the palace?
King Bulgher must be worried.
I'm safe. We have our army,
Odin, and Gara’s Keep.
Gara’s Keep?
Right. I've never been there,
but it's an ancient stronghold.
Odin says we would evacuate
there if we were attacked.
Still, it’s nice the kingdom
is throwing such a grand party.
It's a party for my father.
I wasn't born on the anniversary.
"The day we conquered magic," etc.
It just celebrates the Botican ego.
And your birthday.
I’ll say this. I won't be my father.
I'll treasure family when I'm king.
You mustn’t say that.
King Bulgher is a glorious leader,
stalwart, brave, and true.
You were created to think that, Sam.
Anyway, I think spending the
holiday here with you is the best.
Oh, that reminds me.
I made you a present!
Wow, you didn’t have to do that.
Is that your programming too?
No, I did it because I wanted to.
Wow...
This is wonderful! Thank you!
Why are there two chains?
That’s perfect!
But pendant or no pendant...
...let’s promise to always be
together no matter what, Sam.
Yes, I promise!